Chris Hemsworth's Black Market mercenary
character Tyler rake is ruthless in
beating his opponents to a pulp he turns
out to be night Unstoppable setting up
such fast-paced and elaborate combat
sequences is no small feat as Chris
Hemsworth admitted training for such
scenes was rigorous since the movie is
largely just a series of action scenes
the actor had his work cut out for him
the old saying goes practice makes
perfect and thus a phrase easily applied
to Chris Hemsworth's training to become
Tyler rake the best strategy he found
for learning his moves was simple
repetition going head first into the
choreography over and over again until
it became second nature saying every day
we were shooting one scene would be
rehearsing the next fight scene the
following day in other words the
Australian actor was pulling double duty
every day to ensure that choreography
was just right he confessed to
news.com.eu the whole thing was by far
the most exhausting shoes I've ever been
a part of